chief of staff steve barclay at downing
street is with us also an mp hi it's
good to see you thanks for joining us on
the program this morning we all want to
believe that uh behind that famous black
door known probably the most famous
drawer in the world there are people who
have the utmost integrity instead there
were people drinking until they were
sick
a drunken brawl breaking out red wine
stains on the walls in downing street
laughing at cleaning staff who was
saying you know this is this is not
appropriate
abusing security staff
what's your reaction well the prime
minister was appalled to read that when
he got that report that he himself
commissioned uh yesterday morning that
is why kaye has made such significant
changes and those changes are recognized
in the report
and it's also why he went personally to
apologize to staff yesterday because he
was so shocked by what he read yeah i'm
asking for your reaction too well
equally i recite i was sat with the
prime minister in his office when that
report came in that he had commissioned
and it came into his office at 10
o'clock and like him i was shocked
particularly around what sue gray had
said in terms of the cleaning staff we
had an all-staff meeting yesterday in
downing street
further to that it is why we've had so
many changes in terms of both myself
going into down the street the permanent
secretary a new director of
communication a new principal private
secretary it's why we put procedures now
in place but we were appalled and that's
why as i say the prime minister
apologized is why he went to the house
of commons
and he said how humbled he was to read
about what had happened what were you
most shocked about uh i think what the
disrespect to to staff within the
building i think that was
for someone for me you know growing up
in lancashire um coming from a
background that i do i was particularly
shocked to read that um and he's um
apologized personally to all of the
staff that were affected he went and
apologized to to staffordshire the shift
rotors so it's a question of which stuff
we're in the building yesterday but he's
going to seek out the cleaning staff he
has gone out to seek out stuff to do
that he came to to the house as well in
terms of colleagues and it's why he's
made so many changes in response and and
sue gray recognizes those changes in the
report and say those should now be able
to bed down why did he tell parliament
on the 8th of december that no rules
were broken because as he said in his
statement he was working he was going
for a very short period of time
two events in his work capacity and
indeed that has been reflected k in the
response from the met police now clearly
long after he had gone through incidents
as you say at the top of this item in
terms of their behavior um but this was
there was things that happened when
sometimes he wasn't even in the building
he was at checkers or long after he had
left but he did attend eight of the
sixteen parties that sue grey has events
that sue grey was talking about he also
said he felt a duty to say goodbye to
colleagues
um
so he could say goodbye to a work
colleague
but
people watching this program this
morning couldn't say goodbye to a dying
relative yes and i've seen that in terms
of a commentary and i think all of us i
know as a you said at the start as a
constituency mp i know for my own
families in the constituency that that
was heartbreaking for people that
weren't able to say goodbye i think it
was probably the worst feature one of
the worst features of the pandemic that
people didn't get that moment of being
able to say goodbye i think as was
covered at the time in in the rules
people working in downing street because
of the nature of their jobs working for
the prime minister were there working on
our vaccine were allowed ensuring we had
the ppe working very long hours in
tight-knit
situations and there was a work
exemption for them to be able to work
together and it was in that context that
the prime minister was very briefly just
for usually for a matter of minutes why
would he feel people why would he feel
that he could say goodbye to a work
colleague but people couldn't go to a
graveside because they were already in
the building they were already working
in tight-knit groups they were already
there bottles of wine two bottles of
champagne and a bottle of gin on the
table what sort of workplace is that
what does that say you know these were
very the metas looked at these issues
these were very brief periods of time
prime ministers the nature of a primary
serious job is to go from meeting to
meeting to meeting that is the nature of
their job but at the same time he has
recognized the need for changes he's
made those changes and sue gray herself
has recognized there's been significant
change with a permanent secretary with a
change of leadership team
as a result of the lessons we've learned
meeting names change people advise to
dodge photographers one special advisor
saying our drinks which we seem to have
got away with i mean it was it was a
culture of rule breaking and he is the
chief exec if you will he was presiding
over it all well i think there is a
difference and i think people recognize
between prime ministers going from
meetings to meetings in the course of a
working day
and people who late at night long after
he has gone where behaviors clearly
clearly were inappropriate and that's
why he himself you know i was sat with
him yesterday when the report came in
after 10 o'clock
and he was shocked by that and that's
why he gave the apology that he let me
read exactly what the number 10 special
adviser texted martin reynolds about the
20th of may event just to flag that the
press conference which we were all
watching will probably be finishing
around that time so helpful if people
can be mindful of that as speakers and
cameras are leaving not walking around
waving bottles of wine etc you're
telling me that the prime minister
didn't know about any of that but in
front of us i wouldn't have seen those
sort of emails and messages
and martin reynolds wanted brought it to
his attention even though it was his job
the prime minister's in the course of
his day working very long hours i mean
some of these incidents okay happened
when he wasn't even there he was a but
happened so there's a question and and
he addressed that in his statement to
the house of commons that going to
something for a matter of minutes to
thank people as part of his role as
prime minister is very different to the
very shocking things quite rightly
you're highlighting okay they are
shocking i was shocked to read them
yesterday but they're different to
things that were done in his prime
ministerial capacity so you're basically
doing the job that martin reynolds had
done previously if this sort of stuff
had come to light for you would you have
brought it to the attention of the prime
minister well i actually my role is
different we also have a new principal
private secretary but it's part of a
wider team so the whole team but would
you if you'd known this would you have
brought it to them well i would hope so
but obviously it's difficult to
second-guess the very
intense working conditions i wasn't in
downing street at the time so it would
be difficult for me to second-guess the
pressures the intensity the things that
people
were going through at that time i was
working in the treasury my role was in a
different way but we've reckoned this is
happening at the treasury no it wasn't
did you know well because i was working
in the treasury the treasury is a very
different building and i think one of
the the challenges actually for people
working in daniel street is just the
layout the nature of the building very
very small rooms the treasure actually
is a very different composition uh so
and more people were able to work at
home so just the the structures between
the two yeah
okay so let me put it this way then if
it was happening in downing street now
you wouldn't know because of the way the
building's set up no the point is you
wouldn't know because there's lots of
small rooms and it's a it's a house in
essence and therefore people are much
closer together the the two are just
different workers okay you've been an mp
since
2010 was it your understanding that um
david cameron would have overseen wine
time friday i don't know i mean i was i
was about mentioned p at the time so i
wasn't working in down the street and i
wasn't close to raising maybe because
you weren't you were a brexit secretary
weren't you would you have seen uh one
time fridays when she was in dining
street well again i wasn't working that
you're referring to the press office i
wasn't working uh in the preference i
was actually again working in number
nine at downing street so it's just
simply about where if you're asking to
my own personality
i was working in number nine i think
they would have been happy with what was
happening in down the street well i
don't know i mean you're asking me to to
to help you know exactly what sort of
woman she was and she wouldn't have been
at all happy you know sitting with the
prime minister yesterday he was shocked
and particularly as i say around
the treatment of some by some staff
of others uh in the building and and
that is something the prime minister was
not aware of he was shot by it is why
he's made the significant changes and
his is more than why the lessons are
learnt and indeed that's why he said he
was so humbled yesterday when he
discovered those sort of incidents said
he should accept and bear ultimate
responsibility well he did he went to
the house of commons and he said that he
gave an apology uh he accepted that he
is ultimately uh responsible he
explained uh his role as prime minister
and people were working incredibly
intensively within daniel street during
that time it was an extremely
challenging time but at the same time
it's clear mistakes were made and that's
why
following the interim report the prime
minister changed the senior team and
took on board the comments she made does
the pm have honor
yes he does
does he tell lies no he doesn't he's
been stacked twice for lying well
you know yes my opinion i work very
closely with him he is focused on our
responses russia ukraine he's focused on
the huge challenge economically for
families for your viewers in terms of
the cost of energy the cost of food he's
getting on with the job he got the big
calls right including during korea the
fastest rollout last year we had the
fastest growing economy in the g7 uh on
russia ukraine he has led and i want to
continue to have earlier responses he
has been getting the big calls right but
he accepted in terms of some of these
incidents that there were lessons to be
learned okay martin reynolds is still
working for the government um he's
reportedly being lined up for an
ambassador's job allegra stratton uh was
expected to fall on her sword
you're a modern politician and are you
content with those two scenarios well
it's not appropriate and it never has
been under successive administrations
for ministers start commenting on
individual sort of hr matters obviously
sue gray has addressed some of those
points particularly around
more junior staff versus senior staff
but these will be for the civil service
to take forward in terms of that i
understand that allegra stratton was a
broken woman we saw her outside her
house absolutely bereft by what had
happened and yet the man who was you
know ultimately her boss i suppose um he
looks so he might be an ambassador in
saudi arabia well the point is most of
the people named in this report have
actually left the civil service in terms
of one or two individuals that are still
there as i say i don't think it's
appropriate as a minister to start
speculating so let me ask you do you
think were you were you content with the
way allegra stratton was treated uh well
i wasn't at number 10
that doesn't matter well it's very
difficult for me to know exactly what
happened at that time i wasn't there
what i can say having worked with
allegra at the treasury is just how
highly respected allegra was at the
treasury and still is from ministers and
certainly colleagues that worked with
her there uh we believe that the moving
on to the windfall tax we believe that
that is definitely uh going to go ahead
that's what our tamara has told us this
morning and basically she knows
everything so let's just say that it is
we can agree on tomorrow there we go
there we go so she says it is going
ahead uh this is what the chancellor
told the commons on the 3rd of february
this year of course the windfall tax
stands superficially appealing but we on
the government benches deal with complex
problems in a responsible way here's the
rob the obvious impact of a windfall tax
would be to deter investment it is as
simple as that why's he changed his mind
well he's right that what labour were
proposing in terms of their winful tax
would have deterred investment and we've
just brought out our energy strategy and
a key part of that is how we interact
inward investment indeed as a key part
of responding to the cost of living and
having a long-term energy strategy what
we've said k throughout is we need to do
two things firstly recognize that there
is a huge pressure coming for families
in terms of energy costs and food costs
actually there's a huge pressure now but
we can see coming to the autumn that
that is going to to get worse so we need
to be in a position to have targeted
support to those families but then in
terms of paying for that as we look at
the balance between how much he's done
through debt and how much he's done
through revenue raising we need to do
that in a way that doesn't deter
investment and having worked with the
chancellor throughout the pandemic what
i know he's he's across the detail
incredibly diligent and looks at getting
that balance right in a way that the
windfall tax proposed
by the labour party simply would have
deterred the inward investment that
would have cut across our energy
strategy which part of lancaster are you
from latin
oh posh [ __ ] live in central is very
push what do you think the good people
of lithuan would think this morning
about the timing of this announcement
in what way the fact that it's the day
after the sugree report well no i think
it's because we've had the off-gem uh
guidance or firstly on the sue gravy
report we don't control the timing of
that k i mean that's the timing i don't
know so so so in terms of the timing of
that firstly we don't control the timing
of the supreme report and indeed the
timing got that is shaped by the met
police
investigation what we've always said is
in terms of the fiscal response we
wanted to see from the afghan guidance
what the full uh impact would be
in the autumn of families so that we can
get the design of that package right so
it's absolutely logical we've had that
guidance this week from ofgem that is
why uh the chancellor's coming forward
today it's also in terms of parliament
and the parliamentary timetable
parliament will be off next week for the
jubilee so it's logical before
parliament goes into a recess on the
back of the off-gem guidance this week
that we then bring forward with this
statement we obviously don't control the
timing of the scene are the um
sand dunes still is lovely in them
they're fantastic isn't it beautiful
part of the world thanks very much for
joining us much appreciated thank you